[Music]
you're about to enjoy a free preview
from west side story
this movie is now available
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey get away from me
hey what are you doing
[Music]
oh
it
[Music]
how about you give me some room
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
contain the aggression okay what's the
matter with you guys pretty girls
wanting to dance and all you can think
of is to beat up on each other thank you
officer
all right all right so tonight is a
social experiment boys and girls
brotherhood and all that and you're the
guinea pigs
thank you right on cue
be nice to each other give us some hope
just for a little bit then you can
revert back to your true feral selves
now boys get into a big circle facing in
and girls make a small circle on the
inside facing out
speak english in school sponsored
functions now
everyone please
you heard the man all just fall in
here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
excuse us
boys stepping right girls left when the
music stops you dance with whoever's in
front of you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on give it a chance
[Music]
[Music]
tony
anybody let's see
tony i knew you'd come buddy boy i knew
you'd come hey
come and dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
all right let's go boys
[Music]
real quick
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see what happens next order the entire
movie west side story now available
you